breaking right now at six all employees
at nevada colleges are now required to
be fully vaccinated against covet 19.
thank you for joining us at six i'm
bryan loftis and i'm denise valdez the
nevada system of higher education made
that decision just this afternoon and
employees really don't have a lot of
time to get the vaccine if they have not
already kate houston explains yes this
decision impacts seven nevada colleges
including unlv and csn and one research
institute and these campuses will now be
fully vaccinated since students are now
required to show proof of vaccination
ahead of spring enrollment after nearly
five hours of public comment and
official discussion the entry board of
regents decided all employees will be
mandated to get the covid 19 vaccine
during the meeting nc officials said 80
percent of staff are vaccinated for
those who are not they will receive a
notice of non-compliance on october 15th
a second warning will be sent november
first employees who are not vaccinated
by december 1st will be fired i have
been a happy employee for 20 years
and i will i would be a happy employee
for the next 20 years
but i will not be a subject of an
unnecessary policy that removes basic
rights of an employee i am pleased that
the mandate was passed
despite the public comment that was
sadly overwhelmingly
against it one concern was the impact
this will have on staffing levels and
she says it's working to mitigate that
and there are measures in place for
those who have a change of heart an
employee that is fired for not getting
the vaccine may request to be reinstated
within 30 days of their termination once
they verify they are fully vaccinated
employees can submit medical or
religious exemptions these will be
vetted by nc staff and experts to make
sure that they are complete and accurate